ses mécanos à l'oral me française pour
le bâti les stresser tu sais qui fourche
bonjour à ce que je peux massif est
ballon mais vous pouvez sortir salue
aujourd'hui je suis dans les loges du
grand point virgule pour la nouvelle
édition des hallucinations collectives
et autres illusions fantastique et je
suis de nouveau avec reynald zapata vous
souvenez on avait fait une vidéo
ensemble qui doit s'afficher par là
autour de moi au moment où je vous parle
on avait fait un truc à base de dessins
parce que c'est un sprinteur il a cette
capacité à peindre très rapidement
quelqu'un sur une grande toile et sur
scène et c'est juste impressionnant que
je me demande c'est comment ça se passe
le cheminement pour faire il ya une
phase 2
déjà de recherches iconographiques si tu
veux ils ont beau y écumer les
schtroumpfs une recherche qu'implique
partir de là il ya des premiers croquis
sacs de marque une petite maquette je
veux le transposer en grand sur mon mur
et là je vais commencer à réfléchir
bomba par quoi je vais commencer comment
on se repère là dedans parce que c'est
toi le noir etc
alors d'abord la première chose c'est
que le motif le visuel on doit bien
l'avoir en tête il faut savoir qu'une
tête c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement quadrillée en fait le
analysé ton visage de manière
complètement mathématiquement une
analyse mathématique alors de ton menton
jusqu'au sommet du crâne si je coupe au
milieu je vais tomber sur tes yeux donc
déjà ça c'est un repère majeur ensuite
de tes yeux à tombant comme si je coupe
encore en deux alors puisqu'on a du vol
tu tombe assez bien au cabba et c'est
parce que si c'est face en roumanie sur
la base du nez ok et ensuite je vais
couper encore un nouveau monde est là je
vais tomber sur la ligne de bouchons tu
voitures ont tout à fait le cas non
coldplay n'y a pas de problème dans le
le canon paul crête qui n'insulte pas
voilà quoi tu découpes tout ça et après
ça permet de repérer quand tu fais ton
de voix là et après ça il ya des après
on adapte les techniques de peinture a
vu le dessin à vue quand on prend une
mesure avec nos crayons donc là c'est la
même chose mais qui va beaucoup plus
vite
après on a des cas ou refaire des
profils ça change rien à la grille j'ai
même vu se dessiner à l'enlève alors
dessiné l on verra
l'idée c'est que notre encore une fois
on connaît bien ce sujet mais on ne
connaît bien à l'envers je dis toujours
je connais par coeur son alphabet mais
il le réussit sans problème si le mot à
l'envers moi je vais le faire donc ça
sous l'effet qu'une fois tout ça est
bien un briquet dans la tête près on va
avoir lieu il ya quand même un gros
travail de
de préparation de chorégraphie entre
guillemets en plus de ça ce qu'il dit
pas parce qu'il est modeste mais parfois
il autorise les gens à choisir parmi un
choix plus ou moins restreint donc ça
veut dire que à force de travail tata
tout un catalogue comme ça dans ta tête
oui voilà on va permettre de référé
parce qu'elle a faut que tu retrouves ta
mécanique est à musique exactement alors
bon là avouons que j'ai une petite part
d'un trop quand même parce que imaginons
je tombe sur un personnage que j'ai pas
fait depuis pas mal de temps
ouais j'ai son image en tête parce que
j'ai révisé un peu mes fiches pendant la
semaine mais mais par contre le l'ordre
exact peut-être peut-être 6 passes et
peut-être un manque alors on va dire que
là dessus précise michael jackson avec
le net depardieu s'il nous par exemple
nous on te regarde moi je te regarde si
je veux essayer de reproduire déjà un
personnage un visage
tu vois il faut que je me réfère à ce
quadrillage d'abord voilà des jeunes
jean sa part voit là et tu vas tu
apercevoir que dans ce quadrillage et
des choses qui rentrent pas ok ok et
c'est ce qui fait qu'on ressemble à ce
qu'on rassemble à weedon mais oui oui
c'est sympa nancy mais téhéran
simplement voilà quelqu'un va avoir un
effet un peu plus court un peu plus long
bon ça c'est classique mais tu peux
avoir une carte à la forme générale du
visage tu peux avoir un oeuf
je peux avoir plutôt un carré moi j'ai
commencé par six pieds au lot sleepy
hollow lecavalier s'en faire au moins
faire son col je ferai un petit col
avait fait face à trois mois ses parents
et je trouvais ça intéressant qui nous
explique comment tu faisais en fait moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le point de vue
mental en fait je me demandais à quel
point tel que jusqu'à la projection
et du coup c'est hyper intéressant parce
que c'est ce qu'on voit les mercredis et
les samedis sur cette chaîne c'est que
tu passes par les maths et par la
visualisation
voilà en fait à un moment donné donc
donc voilà il n'y a pas de secret il
faut il faut aller sur la chaîne de
reynald et vous allez voir en action
tout ce qui vient de vous expliquer
c'est la première fois qu'on fait une
vidéo comme ça en fait tout s'est mis à
tourner une astuce ni un blog en fait
j'avais juste envie qui nous explique
comment il faisait si ce genre de format
là vous a plu vous pouvez vous pouvez me
le faire comprendre
évidement d'un petit pouce en l'air si
je le quadrille regarde il ya le pouls
sq
et passez vous pouvez aussi laisser des
commentaires vous y répondre et si vous
avez des questions à poser sur reynald
peut-être que oui passera ils répondent
je ne sais pas tu peux le mentaliser
pour ça rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mandat le blog ciao